GREG GUTFELD IN NEW YORK.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> OUR NOW SLOGAN IN 2020.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS?
KEEP AMERICA GREAT.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> BECAUSE WE ARE DOING SO WELL.
THAT IN ANOTHER FEW YEARS WHEN
WE START THE HEAVY CAMPAIGN,
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN WOULD
NOT WORK OUT WELL.
IT'S KEEP AMERICA GREAT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE HEADED.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PUTTING THE
CAP ON A GREAT WEEK WITH A BIG
RALLY IN INDIANA.
THREE AMERICAN PRISONERS ARE
HOME.
>> IN SINGAPORE I WILL BE
MEETING WITH KIM JONG-UN TO
PURSUE A FUTURE OF PEACE AND
SECURITY FOR THE WHOLE WORLD.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
EKE
EK
>> YOU REMEMBER EVERYBODY ON THE
FAKE NEWS WHERE HE SAID HE WILL
GET US INTO A NUCLEAR WAR!
>> [BOOING].
>> YOU KNOW WHAT GETS YOU INTO
NUCLEAR WARS?
WEAKNESS.
>> AND MR. TRUMP SHOWS THE
GLARING DIFFERENCES BETWEEN HIM
AND HIS PREDECESSOR.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA PAID
1.8-BILLION DOLLARS FOR
HOSTAGES.
>> [BOOING].
>> YOU, NOT ME, THE HOSTAGES
CAME OUT WITH RESPECT.
WE DIDN'T PAY FOR THEM.
THEY CAME OUT FOR NOTHING.
THE OTHERS CAME OUT FOR
1.8-BILLION DOLLARS IN CASH.
YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT?
>> [LAUGHING].
GREG, YOU DON'T LIKE THIS
PHRASE, BUT A LOT TO UNPACK.
>> I HATE THAT PHRASE.
THE RALLY IS HIS
COUNTER-PROGRAMMING.
WHEN YOU -- YOU HAVE ALL OF
THESE ACHIEVEMENTS.
AN AMAZING WEEK FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THE MEDIA IS STILL FOCUSSED ON
LAWYERS AND DEALS AND CONTRACTS.
THEY CAN'T BEAR TO COVER THIS.
IT'S UP TO HIM TO DO HIS OWN
ACHIEVEMENT COUNTER-PROGRAMMING.
YOU WATCH IT.
YOU HAVE TO REMIND YOURSELF,
THERE ARE A LOT OF FIRSTS
HAPPENING HERE.
HE DOES VOICES.
AND THEY SAID THAT WE -- THAT'S
A VERY ENTERTAINING THING.
I LIKE IT WHEN HE TELLS STORIES
LIKE HE DID ABOUT BOBBY KNIGHT.
IF YOU ARE SHOCKED BY THIS --
GOING TO A CONT  CONCERT AND
BEING SHOCKED IT'S LOUD.
THIS IS WHO HE IS.
DAVID BROOKS ADMITTED SAYING
THAT TRUMP'S PAST DEALING WITH
THE VARIOUS CHARACTERS IN AREA
OF REAL ESTATES MAKE HIM THE
BEFORE PERSON FOR NORTH KOREA.
KIM JONG-UN DOESN'T PUT PEOPLE
IN AMENT.
OR MAYBE HE DOES.
>> GREG MAKES THE POINT THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA DOESN'T HAVE TO
LIST HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
BECAUSE HE HAD THE ENTIRE MEDIA
DOING IT FOR HIM.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO TOUT HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN INDIANA THE
HOOSIERS STATE.
WITH SLEEPY JOE DONNELLY.
>> THIS IS WHERE THE PRESIDENT
IS AT HIS BEST.
HE GETS INVIGORATED NO MATTER
WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON.
HE GETS TO SEE THE PEOPLE AND
TALK TO HIM.
COMING ON THE HEELS OF NORTH
KOREA, WHO WOULD NOT FEEL GOOD
ABOUT BRINGING AMERICANS HOME
HEALTHY TO THEIR FAMILIES?
HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK IN
COOPERATIONS TO ARE THE COUNTRY.
>> JUAN, HE SECURED THE RELEASE
OF THE AMERICANS WITHOUT PAYING
THEM OR TRADING TERRORISTS.
>> THIS IS WILD!
FIRST OF ALL -- THE RALLY WAS
LIKE YOU GO TO THE ZOO AND YOU
SEE THE ZOO KEEPERS COME AROUND
THIS TIME OF NIGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE EVENING FEEDING
AND THEY THROW THEM MEAT.
HOW ABOUT IMMIGRATION?
THEY WANT TO TEAR DOWN YOUR
BORDER S
BORDER
BORDERS.
WHAT ABOUT BILL BELICHEK.
THEY THROW THEM IN WITH INDIANA
COACHES.
>> THEY HATE THE PATRIOTS NOW.
>> WHAT ABOUT PELOSI AND OBAMA?
THROW THEM IN THERE AND LOCK
THEM UP.
>> THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR 18
MONTHS.
>> NO, NO, THIS IS NEW.
I THINK THE MID-TERMS.
HE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT 2018 ONCE
HE GOT BEYOND MIKE BRAWN THE
CANDIDATE FOR U.S. SENATE IN
INDIANA.
HE STARTED TALKING ABOUT 2020
AND TALKED ABOUT KEEP AMERICA
GREAT.
AREN'T YOU SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING FOR YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS?
THE KEY FOR ME IN TERMS OF
POLITICS?
TAX CUT PLAN HASN'T PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
>> THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
>> AND THE POLL'S OPINION.
HERE'S THE THING.
LAST NIGHT HE SAID WHEN IT COMES
TO TACKLERS  -- TAXES, THE
DEMOCRATS LED BY PELOSI WANT TO
RAISE YOUR TAXES.
IT'S THESE PEOPLE WHO WILL RAISE
THEM.
>> THANKS FOR TAKING MY JOB.
WE HAVE SOME OF THAT SOUND FROM
PELOSI.
LET'S HEAR IT AND HAVE KENNEDY
REACT.
>> NANCY PELOSI SAID YESTERDAY,
SHE WANTS TO END THE TAX CUTS
AND RAISE YOUR TAXES.
IS THAT LIKE GOOD POLITICS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
THINK ABOUT THAT FROM A
POLITICAL STANDPOINT.
I DON'T THINK HER PARTY WAS TOO
HAPPY.
THEY WANT TO RAISE YOUR TAXES
AND YOURTACTS.
-- TAX CUTS.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS WHERE
EVERYONE FLIES INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING.
>> KENNEDY, JUAN IS WRONG ABOUT
THE TAX CUTS.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE PLENTY OF
THINGS THEY CAN RUN ON.
THERE ARE ALWAYS THINGS YOU CAN
JUDGE WITHIN AN ADMINISTRATION.
DEMOCRATS WITH LOOK AT THINGS
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T DONE
PERFECTLY AND ALTER THOSE AND
THAT CAN BE YOUR NEW PLAN.
DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
ENDING THE TAX CUTS.
PEOPLE GETTING A COUPLE OF GRAND
EXTRA A YEAR, THAT HURTS THEM.
THAT'S NOT JUST CRUMPS.
IF YOU HAD $200 EXTRA EVERY
MONTH IN YOUR PAYCHECK, THAT CAN
BE HELPFUL TO A FAMILY OF 4 AND
A GOOD TRIP TO COSTCO.
WHAT YOU ARE DOING NOW IS
OFFERING RESISTANCE.
THAT FALSE FLAT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SUPER
PROGRESSIVE, IT WON'T BE THIS
VICTORIOUS MID-TERM.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO NORTH
KOREA.
>> FIRST, LET ME RESPOND TO WHAT
YOU SAID.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE CRUMBS.
FOR REPUBLICANS IT BLEW UP THE
DEFICIT.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
LIBERALS SPEND WILDLY.
>> IF YOU RAISE TAXES AND RAISE
SPENDING, NOT ONLY WHAT
DEMOCRATS ALWAYS WANT TO DO.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
RIGHT NOW.
RAISE TAXES TO FUND DOMESTIC
PROGRAMS BUT THEY WON'T CUT
MILTARY SPENDING OR
ENTILINGMENTS AND THE BERNIE
SANDERS PART OF YOUR PARTY WANTS
TO GIVE PEOPLE FREE COLLEGE AND
AMNESTY FOR THOSE WITH
OUTSTANDING COLLEGE DEBT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT NORTH KOREA
AND ADDRESS SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
HE WAS TALKING TO THE
NAYSAYERERS WHO WERE UP IN ARMS
ABOUT THE TWEETS AND RHETORIC HE
WAS USING AGAINST KIM JONG-UN.
I THINK THAT IS FAIR.
WE DIDN'T KNOW -- THERE IS NO
WAY PEOPLE CAN FORESEE THE
OUTCOME.
IT GAVE HILLARY CLINTON AND
PEOPLE LIKE THAT TO SAY, IF I
WERE PRESIDENT, I WOULD HAVE
SAID NICE THINGS TO KIM JONG-UN
AND HE IS CALLING HIM LITTLE
ROCKET MAN AND WE ARE ALL GOING
TO DIE.
THEN THERE IS A HUGE 90 DEGREE
SHIFT FROM THAT.
NOW WE HAVE 3 AMERICAN HOSTAGES
HOME AND ON THE ROAD TO A
DIPLOMAT SIT DOWN.
>> THE SINGAPORE SUMMIT.
>> WOULD HILLARY CLINTON HAVE
GOTTEN US HERE?
>> DON'T COUNT YOUR EGGS BEFORE
THEY HATCH.
YOU ARE WAY AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
>> GREG, HE HAS PEACE,
PROSPERITY AND SECURITY.
ISIS IS DEAD.
PEACE ON THE PENINSULA.
I WILL WALK AWAY FROM THE TABLE
IF I HAVE TO AND PEOPLE HAVE AN
EXTRA $2,000 IN THEIR POCKET.
THAT'S IMPORTANT WHEN THE LEFT
TALKS ABOUT STORMY AND
IMPEACHMENT.
>> AMERICA IS LIKE DISNEYLAND.
THE MEDIA IS STUCK IN THE
TEACUPS.
THEY ARE NAUSEATED GOING AROUND
AND AROUND.
HOW DID IRAN BEGIN?
ANGRY TWEET.
BUT THEY ARE TWEETING.
>> YES.
>> THEY'RE ACTUALLY --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> BUT THERE IS COMMUNICATION.
IT'S NEGATIVE COMMUNICATION, BUT
THIS IS HOW NORTH KOREA STARTED.
IT COULD HAPPEN AGAIN.
IF HE KEEPS WINNING LIKE THIS,
THE DEMOCRATS --
>> QUICK, LOOKING AT THE
MID-TERM ELECTIONS.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY AND
THE TIGHTENING OF THE GAP
LOOKING FAVORABLE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND NOW FAVORABLE FOR
THE REPUBLICANS FOR THE HOUSE.
FEELING THAT AS WELL.
AND THE CROWD.
>> YES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> SICK EVER WEB -- SICK OF
WINNING.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON HIS FACE.
>> IF TRUMP SWITCHES PARTIES AND
BECOMES A DEMOCRAT.
>> HE CHANGED PARTIES BEFORE.